♪ ♪
>> Greg: WOULD YOU PAY TO
DELETE A REGRETFUL TWEET?
ACCORDING TO INFORMATION BY AN
INDEPENDENT RESEARCHER, WHATEVER
THAT MEANS, FOR 299 A MONTH
TWITTER IS CONSIDERING A NEW
SERVICE CALLED "TWITTER BLUE"
WHICH ALLOWS THEM TO UNSCENTED
TWEET FOR A FEW SECONDS AFTER
POSTING IT.
OR WHO EXCELLENTLY RETWEETED
ANYTHING FROM CHRISSY TEAGAN.
WHERE'D SHE GO?
OUR USEFUL TOOL IF YOU USED YOUR
REAL ACCOUNT FOR A TWEET THAT
SHOULD HAVE COME FROM YOUR
ANONYMOUS STEVE DOOCY FAN
ACCOUNT.
HYPOTHETICALLY.
TWITTER ALLOWING USERS TO
ORGANIZE FAVORITE TWEETS INTO
FOLDERS INSTEAD OF GETTING SOME
FRESH AIR.
DR. DREW, HAS THERE EVER BEEN A
TWEET HE WISH HE COULD ON SAND?
>> I'M SURE THERE ARE MANY.
BUT IT JUST REMINDS ME ABOUT HOW
MUCH WE ARE TRYING TO CONTROL
LANGUAGE THESE DAYS.
CONTROLLING THE LANGUAGE SEEMS
TO BE THE OVERRIDING IMPULSE
EVERYBODY HAS.
I'VE BEEN THINKING ABOUT
SOMETHING ABRAHAM LINCOLN SAID
RECENTLY -- I'VE BEEN TO GET
ABOUT IT RECENTLY.
IF YOU CALL AN ELEPHANT'S TRUNK
A LEG, HOW MANY LEGS DOES AN
ELEPHANT HAVE?
FOUR, BECAUSE CALLING IT A TRUNK
DOESN'T MAKE IT A LEG.
AND WE ARE SO BUSY TRYING TO
CONTROL LANGUAGE THESE DAYS THAT
WE ARE JUST PREOCCUPIED WITH
WORDS AND TWITTER AND MESSAGING
AND IT'S A BIG MESS, WE SHOULD
BE GETTING OFF TWITTER NOT
PAYING THEM MORE.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW THE SPIDER?
INSTEAD OF AN ELEPHANT?
>> THIS WOULD BE A GOOD TIME TO
DO IT.
>> FOR $2.99 COME ON DOING MY
TWEET THAT I WAS GOING TO BE ON
THE SHOW.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A REALLY GOOD
IDEA.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: YOU ARE NOT EVEN ON
TWITTER, ARE YOU?
>> MATT WHITAKER 46.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, THIS SEEMS
LIKE SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE UP
YOUR ALLEY.
>> YEAH, BECAUSE YOU TWEET
SOMETHING AND IT'S SO GOOD, AT
LEAST MINE ARE, AND THEN YOU
NOTICE HE MADE A LITTLE TYPO AND
PEOPLE MIGHT THINK THAT YOU WERE
TWEETING WHILE YOU WERE
DRINKING, EVEN THOUGH THAT
SOMETHING YOU WOULD NEVER DO.
>> Greg: IT'S FUNNY, THE ONES
I REGRET I JUST DON'T REMEMBER.
>> THE NEXT DAY, WHAT IS THIS?
>> Greg: DID YOU SEE THE PRESS
ABOUT SOMETHING?
SOME OF THE STUFF WORDS
COMPLETELY, COMPLETELY IN MY
HEAD AND INNOCUOUS.
APPARENTLY PEOPLE LIKE TO TAKE
THESE OUT OF CONTEXT.
CYRUS, DO YOU EVER WISH LIFE HAD
AN UNDO BUTTON?
>> EVERY MORNING WHEN I GET UP.
AS I WALK ON THE PLANE HEADING
TO NEW YORK.
IT WOULD BE SO NICE.
BUT I LIVE IN THE REAL WORLD.
THIS IS STUPID, DON'T GIVE THEM
A DIME, YOU CAN'T TAKE IT BACK.
SOMEBODY WILL HAVE IT, AND EVEN
WORSE ON TOP OF YOUR BAD TWEET,
HE ATTEMPTED TO DELETE HIS
TWEETS.
SO YOU REALLY KNOW HOW EVIL AND
BAD HE IS.
THIS IS A SET UP, THIS IS A
HORRIBLE SET UP FOR SOMEONE WHO
SAYS SOMETHING AND TRIES TO
DELETE IT OR THEY MAKE THE
MISTAKE.
I WAS 12 YEARS OLD AND I SAID
SOMETHING DUMB ON TWITTER.
I TRIED TO FIX IT, BUT WHILE I'M
TRYING TO FIX IT IT'S RETWEETED
EVERYWHERE AND THEN YOU CAN'T
GET DRAFTED UP TO 21 BECAUSE YOU
MESSED UP WHEN YOU WERE 12.
>> AND TWITTER SUCKS NOW.
SO IT'S A DYING THING.
TO SPEAK OF THE FINEST PERSON AT
THE BAR LEFT THE BAR AND NOW YOU
ARE STUCK WITH HIS WEIRD FRIEND.
>> DID TIFFANY TWEET?
OF GOT TO LOOK INTO THAT.
>> THAT'S AGAIN, HOLD A NEW.
>> Greg: IT'S LIKE THAT BIG
STAIN REMOVER THEY USED OF THE
SUPERMARKET BEFORE YOUR TIME --
WHAT IS IT CALLED?
THE STEAM REMOVER.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT'S CALLED,
BUT IT'S TRUE.
THE MOMENT YOU REMOVE A TWEET,
SOMEBODY'S GOING TO HAVE A
SCREEN GRAB OF IT IMMEDIATELY
AND YOU ARE GUILTY.
I THINK THE DASH WHAT WOULD MAKE
TWITTER THE BEST THING IS TO
REMOVE TRENDS.
BECAUSE HOW WOULD THE LAZY MEDIA
KNOW WHAT A STORY IS?
I WOULD SAY 80% OF THE STORIES
THAT WE ARE SEEING RIGHT NOW OUR
PRODUCER OR SOMEBODY ON THE SHOW
IS LOOKING AT TWITTER TRENDS
SEEN WHAT'S TRENDING AND GO,
THIS PERSON MUST'VE SAID
SOMETHING P LET'S GO AFTER THAT
PERSON BUT IF YOU REMOVE THE
TWITTER TRENDS, THEY WOULD ALL
HAVE TO GO BACK TO DRUDGE.
THAT WAS A JOKE.
HE CAN'T GO BACK TO DRUDGE.
BECAUSE DRUDGE SUCKS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: IT'S TRUE.
>> YOUR POINT IS WELL TAKEN.
THEY GET TWISTED AND AS THEY ARE
TRENDING, THEY GET TWISTED INTO
SOMETHING ELSE IN THE MEDIA
REPORTS THAT AS FACT.
>> EXACTLY.
IF YOU CAN SEE FAKE NEW